CARTER MORGAN: And now
we put it all together.
If you missed the last four
episodes, check them out.
Link below.
But for those of you
who haven't, let's
check out how to get
started with Kubernetes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- With a whole universe
of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
[PLAYBACK ENDS]
CARTER MORGAN: Hey, guys.
Thanks for joining me on
this culminating video.
Before we talked
about containers
and some other things, but
it was mostly theoretical.
It would be great to see
an example in action.
What do you think?
KASLIN FIELDS: Yeah,
sounds good to me.
You remember in
the last episodes
how we talked about containers
and deploying those containers
onto Kubernetes?
CARTER MORGAN:
Yeah, I went back,
I rewatched all
the old episodes.
We talked about nodes.
We talked about
containers, and we even
talked about the basic
Kubernetes API objects.
But one thing was we deployed
everything imperatively,
which you said wasn't
going to scale well, right?
KASLIN FIELDS: Right.
So this time I'm
going to show you how
to deploy an app declaratively.
CARTER MORGAN: Great.
I can't wait to
see how it works.
KASLIN FIELDS: Now
we're going to explore
how to deploy applications in
containers declaratively using
Kubernetes.
If you remember
in the last video,
we talked about
deployments in Kubernetes
and how to create them.
But the command that we
used in our last video
to create a deployment
was imperative.
We told Kubernetes exactly
what we wanted it to do
and it did it.
In the real world,
we don't really
want to do things that way.
We want to do
things declaratively
by having a file that
describes or declares
what we want things to be like.
And then we have Kubernetes do
the hard work of figuring out
how to make that happen.
Having our state defined
declaratively in files
allows us to do some cool
things, like make changes
to our deployments
by just changing
the file describing it.
We can also track those
changes through source control
and make use of great tools
for deploying applications
at scale, like
continuous integration
and continuous deployment tools.
So to start with, let's
create a deployment
like we did in the last
video, but this time we'll
do it declaratively.
So here you can see that I'm
in Google Cloud platform,
and I'm using the
Cloud Shell terminal
to interact with a
Kubernetes cluster
that I have already created.
And if I run LS here,
you'll see that I'm
in a directory that has some
subdirectories and some files.
So the files for my
microservice application
that I'm going to need to create
that microservice application
in Kubernetes are all
in these directories.
So the first one that
I'm going to look at is
deployments/hello.yml.
So in this case, I have
all of my files separated
by the type of Kubernetes
resource that they define.
You could do this in
all sorts of ways,
you don't have to do it with
this structure or anything.
It's just the way
that it is here.
So let's take a look at this.
If you remember
the last video, we
had told Kubernetes what it was
that we wanted it to create,
which is a deployment
in this case.
So we're doing that again here.
We're giving that
deployment a name.
We're telling Kubernetes
a number of replicas
that we want of the pods that
will be in this deployment.
You remember that we
went over those as well.
And so here, we are defining
the actual containers that we're
going to be running,
the container image,
and a bit more
information about that.
And you'll also
see down here, we
have a liveness probe
and a readiness probe,
which we didn't really
go for last time.
But they are tools that
Kubernetes provides
to help make sure that
your application is up
and ready to receive traffic.
So there's a bit more that you
can learn about deployments.
As you can see,
this is a fairly--
it's not really
that long, but there
are a few components in it that
are worth learning a bit more
about.
So if you want to look into
deployments a bit more,
I'd recommend it.
So this is what we mean by
declaring our desired state.
All of the
information about what
we want this deployment to
look like is here in this file.
And if we wanted
to make a change,
like changing the
image that we're
going to be running
in this deployment,
we could do that in this file
and we could track that change
through source control.
So the next thing I'm
going to do, actually,
I want to look at one more
file before I create anything.
So let me look at,
within services,
I have another file
called Hello hello.yml.
So if you remember
from the last video,
we created our deployment
with our application
but then we needed some way
to reach our application.
And we did that by creating
a Kubernetes service.
So this is what
this is going to do.
This is creating another
Kubernetes service
that will allow
artists to connect
to our Hello application,
which will be
deployed in its own deployment.
So the service definition
is pretty simple.
It just has a name
for the service.
It has a selecter which
tells the service how
to find the back ends
that it is serving,
and then it has some
port information
that will allow us to actually
reach that application.
So if I want to
create these and I
want to do it in a declarative
way, what I'm going to do
is run kubectl apply dash f
and give it the file name.
So let's say
deployments/hello.yml.
And I can do more
than one at a time.
I can just add another dash f
here, and specify my service,
and create my service
at the same time.
So that's pretty cool.
The kubectl apply command
doesn't know which
API object you're creating.
So you can specify
it in the file
and then just give
it those files.
So it's pretty versatile.
So let's go ahead
and create those.
So you can see that my
deployment and my service
were created.
But it wouldn't be a
microservice application
if it wasn't split up
into multiple services.
So the next service that
I'm going to deploy,
I'm going to deploy in
exactly the same way.
I'm going to do
kubectly apply dash f,
and then grab
another deployment.
And this time I'm going
to deploy my frontend.yml.
So for this application I've
added in an Nginx server,
which will act as my front end.
And by the way, if you want to
try this stuff out for yourself
and follow along, or just
kind of play around with it,
check out the links below.
We'll have some information for
you to get hands on with this.
So we're going to
kubectl apply and we'll
give it a file for our
front end deployment.
And once again, we're going
to need a service for that.
So let's create our
frontend.yml service as well.
Now, an interesting
thing here is
I'm using the
kubectl apply command
because, if that
resource doesn't exist,
the apply command will go
ahead and create the resource.
So I didn't have a front end
deployment or a front end
service before.
So I went ahead
and created those.
But if I were to run
this command again,
you'll see that it says that
the front end and the deployment
and its service were unchanged.
So if we were to make a
change to our deployment,
like I said earlier, if we were
to update the container image
or something like that
in our deployment file,
where we have declared
what we want our deployment
to look like, then we would be
able to just apply that change.
And in the case of
deployments, there
are settings within
Kubernetes that you
can use to tell it how to
roll out that change when
you apply a new change.
So in that way, this is
a very declarative way
to create resources
in Kubernetes.
But now that I have an Nginx
component to my application,
there's some
configuration information
that I want to pass
into my Nginx server.
And it didn't really make
sense to add that stuff
into the container definition.
And it didn't really
make sense to add
that at any point along the
way in creating the Kubernetes
deployment.
So how am I going to get that
configuration information
into my Nginx server now?
Luckily, Kubernetes has a tool
for that called ConfigMaps.
A config map lets you map
your configuration information
to your application running
in a Kubernetes deployment.
I already have a
file here, which
has the configuration
information that I
need for my Nginx front end.
And it's in nginx/frontedn.conf.
So you can see here
that this is a bunch
of configuration information
for my Nginx front end.
But you'll see that
it's not in yml form.
So this is not actually
declaratively declared.
So I'm going to have
to create this just
using the configuration
file as it is.
So what I'm going to do
is run kubectl create.
Configmap is the
type of Kubernetes
object that I want to create.
And I'm going to
give that a name,
which I'm just going to call
it Nginx front end conf,
and I'm going to tell it I want
it to create that config map
from a file with
information file,
which is nginx/frontend.conf.
Cool.
So this, we'll go ahead
and create the config map
from that configuration
information
that I showed you a minute ago.
But I have another problem.
I want to run this application
a bit more securely
and I want to use TLS with it.
But for that, I'm going
to need to pass it
some TLS certs,
which I don't really
want to pass in a config map
because that information is
just kind of plain text.
I want to make sure that that
information is kept more, well,
secret.
So Kubernetes has a great
tool for this called Secrets.
Now, there are a lot
of different tools
for passing sensitive
information in Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes Secrets
might not be the best tool
for your use case.
You'll have to do a little bit
of research to figure it out.
But in my case,
Kubernetes Secrets
are going to be just fine.
They'll encrypt the
information that I'm
passing into my application.
So let's go ahead and create a
secret to pass my application,
the TLS certs that
I have for it.
So kubectl create is what
I'm going to use again.
Secrets are very
similar to ConfigMaps,
except they're for
secret information.
So create a secret.
And there are a few
different types of secrets,
but for this one I'm just
going to create a generic one.
And I'm going to give
it a name, tls-certs.
And I'm going to create that,
once again, from a file.
And that will be the TLS certs
that I have in my directory.
So that secret was created.
And now there's one more piece
of my microservice application.
And that is an
authentication tool
that I've added into
the microservice.
So what that's going to look
like is, once again, coming
back to that trusty
kubectl apply dash f,
and I'm going to grab a service
for my auth.yml component
of my micra service.
And of course, I'm going to
need something for that service
to serve, which will be
a deployment one again.
And that's going to
be auth.yml as well.
And I appear to have
mistyped something.
Oh, I didn't put a dash f
before my deployments file.
So you do have to
put a dash f for each
file that you're passing it.
So there you go.
You can see that
I've gone on ahead
and created the service
in the deployment
for my authentication
component of my microservice.
And that's it.
That's my whole
microservice that I'm
going to be showing you today.
But how do I make sure
that it's working properly?
Well, the best way is
always to test, right?
So I'm going to run
kubectl get services,
or just svc for short.
And I want to get the
information for my front end.
So you'll see that
my front end service
is of type load balancer.
In this case, that means that it
created an actual load balancer
resource in Google Cloud, and
that external load balancer
resource has created
an external IP for us
that we will actually
be able to use
to reach the application
that I've created.
So I'm going to copy that IP
and I'm going to export it
as a variable just to
make my following commands
a little bit easier.
EXTERNAL_IP.
And give it that number.
OK.
So I've created my variable.
So now I can run a
curl command to test
to make sure that my application
is running correctly.
And if you'll
remember earlier, we
incorporated some
security capabilities
into this application.
But let's say that I
just curled that IP.
What would happen?
Actually, I'm just
going to post it in,
even though I just did that.
So if I curl that,
nothing happens.
Why is that?
Of course, it's
because we set up TLS
and we set up some
security measures.
So now we're going to have to
connect to this application
using HTTPS.
A bit more securely.
So I'm going to run curl dash k
htttps:// and give it that IP.
And there you go.
So we've got our
message output of hello.
And that's all I expected
this application to do.
So I know the application
is up and running properly.
But I also incorporated this
authentication capability.
And so I can also connect
to this application
as a specific user and
make use of it that way.
So for that, I'm going to
have to get a token to log in
as a specific user.
So what that's
going to look like--
whoops.
I already did it.
So I'm going to
go ahead and enter
the password for the user.
So what you can see
here is I set up
a token, which equals
a curl command, logging
in as a specific user.
I'm grabbing the token
from that log in.
I had to enter the
password for that user.
And so now I have this
token that I can use
to access the website as well.
So now I'm going to go ahead
and run a curl command where
I am passing in that token.
So I'm logging in
as a specific user.
And if I run that, I
get the same result.
So I know that I can
reach my application
by using this authorization
at capability that I edited.
So cool stuff.
I went through and I created
deployments and config maps
and secrets.
And for the deployments
and the services,
I did it in a declarative
way, using these files
that I can then go in and
make changes to, track
those changes, and do a
lot of really cool stuff
with automation and running
applications at scale.
So this is going to
be really useful.
CARTER MORGAN: Great.
So that's how I can run my
application declaratively.
KASLIN FIELDS: Right.
Running things
declaratively is really
useful in the real world.
Running your deployments
based on a file
makes it easy to set up
CI/CD, source control,
and other processes that are
useful for running applications
at scale.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow.
Thanks to Kaslin
for taking the time
to show me how this all works.
This wraps up the most
basic Kubernetes objects.
Next time we'll start looking
into more advanced use cases
and features of Kubernetes.
Stay tuned.
Oh, and be sure to follow
along in the Codelab link below
to walk through this code
if you want to get hands-on.
And if you enjoyed this
episode, subscribe for more.